[Musique]
géranium chisanthème cosmos ou encore
pensé ces fleurs qui tapissent nos
villages sont primordiales pour obtenir
cette fameuse distinction apposée en
dessous du panneau d'accueil de la ville
il s'agit des labels ville et village
fleuis et cette année 76 communes ont
été distinguées dans les
ivelines cel la belle récompense les
collectivités qui offrent un cadre de
vie agréable à leurs habitants et à
leurs visiteurs c'est une distinction
qui va de une à quatre fleurs l'objectif
améliorer la qualité de vie promouvoir
l'attractivité des villes mais aussi
agir pour l'environnement pour l'obtenir
plusieurs critères sont nécessaires le
fleurissement sur l'ensemble de la
commune les moyens de gestion pour
entretenir le patrimoine en respectant
la biodiversité ou encore les actions
pour augmenter la fréquentation
[Musique]
touristique parmi les petites nouvelles
brevval qui reçoit pour la première fois
le labelle une fleur mais aussi
Montesson nflette et Fontenet
Saint-Père parmi les communes labellisé
deux fleurs trois villes sont
distinguées dans le nord des ivelines
bruillant-veexin mantelaville et Orgeval
plus à l'est les villes de croissis sur
scène et Guill en cour reçoivent
également le label de fleurs etpone
toute nouvelle ville labellisée passe
aussi directement à de
fleurs enfin trois villes evel ont reçu
le label trois fleurs il s'agit de marli
Leroi une commune de 16000 habitants
situés entre Versailles et Saint-Germain
en lait Andry une commune de 13000
habitants situés entre Chantelou les
viges et hacher et voisin le Bretonneux
une commune de 10000 habitants situés
entre guillencour et Montini le
Bretonneux ces trois villes rejoignent
ainsi les 22 autres villes qui ont le
label trois fleurs dans le
département il ne s'agit pas d'une ville
mais de deux véis ville coublé et
versaill possèdent toutes les deux
quatre fleurs ce qui font d'elles les
villes les plus fleuries des Yvelines
[Musique]
oui la ville de la selle saintclou par
exemple a été récompensée par le Prix du
patrimoine arboré avec déjà trois fleurs
à son actif ce prix lui est décerné pour
son exemple en terme de politique
globale de l'environnement les soins
apportés à la mise en œuvre de nouvelles
plantations ou encore la qualité des
Tails et des élagages crois si sur scène
à quant à elle est récompensé par le
prix de la biodiversité et de la
transition écologique le prix national
du jardinier a été remis à épone il
récompense le travail de qualité mené
sur plusieurs années et distingue
particulièrement les bénévoles et agents
communaux qui se sont investis de façon
exceptionnelle dans le fleurissement de
la commune enfin fontené saintbert a
reçu le prix du village
remarquable